ich halte berlin für eine verlorene
stadt
sei es jetzt im bereich der
kleinkriminalität
sei es also meinem bereich der
organisierten kriminalität
die familie busacca ist natürlich auch
eine größe dafür bekannt dass es aus dem
drogenmenge straftaten gibt gerüchten
zufolge wird es in berlin wahrscheinlich
kaum ein wohnungsbordell geben was nicht
sozusagen schutzgeld an die familie
bezahlt sie sind auch bekannt dafür dass
sie schwere raub tat begangen haben
diese brutalität die sie am tag gelegt
haben und die machen das einfach
entweder gibt es auf die fresse oder es
wird mit geld geregelt unser
rechtssystem wird nicht anerkannt
es gibt hier einen keller es sollen dort
auch leute untergebracht worden seien
soweit wir wissen sind die nicht alle
freiwillig heruntergegangen um einen
klaren zu werden müssen sie viel werden
müssen wir bald ausüben seien wie stöcke
eines clans mit der zahl von den jungs
erzählen will massa war das
unangefochtene oberhaupt dieser familie
darauf hat ist nachgekommen einen helfer
man hat netzwerke geschaffen in die
politik in behörden in richtung medien
dass ich bin schon eher der machen
bushido hat natürlich eine hauptrolle
gespielt das war ja eine der
haupteinnahmequellen
mann ist über die roten teppiche
gelaufen man hat schon gewissen status
erreicht den man sonst natürlich nie
erreicht hätte
man hat schon immer sehr deutlich
gemerkt arafat war derjenige der das
sagen hatte bushido eigentlich eher
weniger der war eher der zurückhaltende
die richterin und das schämen sich in
grund und boden
natürlich wir sind aufeinander gestoßen
arab hat es von null auf hundert in
einer sekunde
also ich habe schon gemerkt ich wurde
beobachtet und es standen auch
tatsächlich zwei personen bei mir vor
der privaten wohnanschrift ich bin kein
schritt in berlin ohne meine waffe
gegangen nirgendwo
war ich
zu meiner familie gemeinsam initiiert
aber wenn wir können und so mehr zu
dieser sache zu klären untereinander ist
das verhältnis nach außen hin ist es
natürlich immer eine einheit aber wir
wissen dass es nicht ganz so ist wenn
man aber zwei einfach mist gebaut hat
was man dafür alles
leute die höheren einnahmen
doch garnicht menschen
[Musik]